[Music]
things are
disappearing at an increasing rate both
animals and cultural sites
3d scanning is a way to digitally
capture the world and make a copy of
something
my personal mission is to build
technologies to help explore the worlds
and the disappearing
things around us whether they're
cultural heritage sites archaeology
sites or the natural world
[Music]
come here even here in indonesia i don't
think a lot of people have seen the
sumatran rhino
the bars are nice and wide apart so the
cameras will be able to look through
them
we won't have to see any of the bars and
tarp over the top will keep the cameras
dry if it starts raining
being able to use this scan as an
education and outreach tool
to get everyone excited about saving
this animal is a great use of the
technology
we're using a technique for 3d scanning
called photogrammetry
we're taking many many photographs and
merging them together to get 3d depth
perception
it's because of 3d cam this is actually
the first
animal that we've tried to 3d scan and
being the sumatran rhino very important
critically endangered animal is a pretty
high bar to set for us
now we'll get all the super clamps on
them and then we'll mount the cameras
and we'll do a focus test the led
lighting
see what we got sounds good cool all
right
so doing 3d scannable live animal is
very different than doing a stationary
object
with the live animal it moves this is
changing its 3d geometry enough
that you can't just use a single camera
what you have to do is capture all the
images that you're going to use to
stitch into 3d at once
you big beautiful animals oh
did you hear them
you might have seen something fierce
so the solution is an array of cameras
we put together 18 cameras that are all
triggered so they fire
exactly at the same millisecond
we can basically freeze time and have
all of these images of the rhino at the
exact same
instant so we can build these into a 3d
model
don't super worry about exactly where
they're set
yet that's pretty good
these cameras are spread approximately
equally in three rows
and all of those cameras come back to
central boxes which are triggering each
camera at once when we press a single
remote
yup these ones
800 kilogram rhino just totally
cooperating and doing this crazy dance
to get scanned
so beyond just doing a single capture we
freeze the animal in time
we're doing other analysis in video like
animal gait analysis so we can see how
the rhino moves we can see how its head
moves its leg moves its tails its ears
we'll be able to take these scans and
actually animate it so we'll have a
rhino
that looks photorealistic that's walking
around the way that it actually moves
and how it's musculature and skin moves
with it
i'm actually surprised that the fur and
stuff on the back didn't do us that bad
[Music]
leave the posts where they are though
that's his favorite ear scratching post
right there too
so once we have this data all processed
and our artists clean it up and
make it look perfect the end application
here is that we can have
a digital copy of this rhino that can be
fully articulated move around in 3d
space
so you can put on a headset and stand
next to the sumatran rhino and be one of
the few people
that have ever been able to do that
being able to look at it from all sides
being able to walk up and look in the
animal's eye
creates an emotional connection that's
beyond what you can get from a flat
video or photograph
the ultimate application of this will be
to bring the rhino to everyone
[Music]
you